welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy whose wife prefers a machine to
the real thing
and that's not a mecha godzilla joke hey
other than that now godzilla vs kong
has made a big impact and the movie is
now the highest grossing film since the
pandemic began
it's got a ton of things going on in it
and after binge watching the entire
monster verse
i'm going to be pointing out some of the
insane details easter eggs and callbacks
that you
specifically missed yes you you didn't
catch these because you're an idiot now
probably
not the best way to start the video and
i'm sure you caught some of them
but if you enjoy it then please smash
the thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe for videos like this each and
every day
with that out of the way thank you for
clicking this and i'm sure you're not an
idiot sorry for that
now let's get into godzilla versus [ __ ]
okay so the movie is very much centered
around the idea that the two apex
predators cannot coexist
and this godzilla goes on the warpath
trying to retain his reign as king of
the monsters
kong himself is of course an apex
predator but we also learned that
godzilla is hunting for mechagodzilla
who just so happens to be made by a
company called apex
though it's slightly on the nose and i'm
probably the idiot now for having to
point it out
it does show the attention to detail
that the script has and that the company
are very much plotting to play the pair
off against one another
in the hopes that their machine monster
can take the dominant role as the apex
predator
mechagodzilla is built on sub-level 33
which just so happens to be a reference
to the end 1933
which is when king kong was first
released we learned that it's powered
with the help of the consciousness of a
ghidorah head
which we last saw at the end of king of
the monsters in that we discovered that
the titan was actually an
alien that communicated telepathically
so it does make sense that it's able to
control another skull located inside the
head of mechagodzilla
the movie pulls from other things in the
long and rich history between the pair
and the plot itself echoes several
classic godzilla movies
including godzilla vs mechagodzilla and
terror of mechagodzilla
both films center around the g-man being
framed as someone who's turned against
the human race
and they also have several key moments
that are repeated in this film
for example godzilla and mechagodzilla
both fire their atomic breaths directly
at one another
and both moments end with mechagodzilla
winning the death of the mecca g's are
also extremely similar across
all the movies as in each and every one
of them the monster is beheaded
now though mechagodzilla was originally
made by aliens
in godzilla vs mechagodzilla 2 it was
changed up so that it was humanity that
created the monster
which this movie of course aligns with
in 2002's godzilla against mecca
godzilla
the machine was built using the bones of
a gajira and these
eventually overpowered the machine and
took over similar to what happens during
this movie
mecha g kills a skull crawler at one
point using the same move that godzilla
did on the mutos in the 2014 film
and in the credits we learned that this
is referred to as the kiss of death
the man who controls mechagodzilla is
named ren serazara
and he is actually the son of ishiro
played by ken watanabe
from interviews and behind the scenes
information we know that there was a
vast amount of things got out of the
movie including a subplot involving him
and how he views the attacks by godzilla
as personal
because of his father's death which was
linked to the character we also meet
bernie hayes played by brian tyree henry
who's the host of the titantruth podcast
the logo of this looks extremely similar
to the eye from the 1998 movie
which i actually really like yeah i
haven't seen it in a while i
probably haven't watched it since i was
10 years old but i like it so
that's just me now his podcast episodes
also include one called mothra's
pregnancy theory
and this is something that pulls on the
long and rich history of the titans
mothra was killed in king of the
monsters but it was theorized that some
form of the character could return to
its child
which has allowed the creature to come
back in several monster movies
this egg was spotted at the end of king
of the monsters making me think that we
will save mothra for another movie
now an article on emma russell can also
be seen at one point
which asks whether she was a villain or
savior in the prior movie she wanted to
thanos the population with the titans
and this would allow the survivors to
have more resources and live a better
quality of life now the eye that bernie
comes across looks very similar to the
one from a terminator
the machine itself is much in the same
vein as that machine
because it's based on an organic
creature and has been tasked with taking
it down
you also hear a clanging noise which is
repeated three times
and this is similar to mechagodzilla's
raw which too happens three times
[Music]
madison and rusty from deadpool later
meet him at a restaurant
the sign of which looks like the
legendary logo now the film centers
heavily around a journey to the center
of the hollow earth
and houston brooks played by corey
hawkins first brought it up on skull
island
he said that he'd actually written a
paper on it and this theory itself
emanates from the 17th century where it
was first brought up by edmund haley who
you probably know from naming the comet
the idea of the hollow earth has
appeared throughout the monster verse
including king of the monsters
where it was mentioned by dr rick
stanton played by bradley whitford
whitford discussed how he too had
theorized the hollow earth
and how vortexes around the planet led
into it which we get confirmed in this
movie
the location very much parallels
zootopia which was introduced in
godzilla vs megalon
this world existed beneath the surface
and it was home to several kaijus which
is sort of repeated here now we joined
kong and skull island under a dome
and learning the film that the storms
that circulate their location eventually
closed in on
it and wiped out almost all of the life
there these storms can actually be seen
in a blink and you'll miss a moment
as we circulate the dome itself this is
very similar to the truman show
and i don't know if it's intentional or
not but we watch as the character
trapped within it
slowly starts to realize their reality
is a lie
okay okay that's that's that's a reaches
knit now the first shot of the film
opens on the sun
which is something that was also shown
in the first shot of kong skull island
the movie also ended with his eye
turning into the sun
and it's like poetry they rhyme now kong
throws a tree in order to bring down the
hex panels that surround the dome
and this is a maneuver that we saw him
doing in skull island when the
helicopters first arrived
he also rips it apart some of how he did
in skull island
when facing down against a skull crawler
at this point we're introduced to gia
who holds a monkey idol to him this is a
flip on the classic imagery of a girl
being held up to kong
which is commonplace in several of the
sacrifice scenes that have appeared
throughout most of the movies featuring
him kong is very much in the search for
a home
and the name jira itself translates to
that in chinese
from here we cut to the credits and see
several interesting nods to what's going
to happen in the film
credit scenes like this have appeared in
most of the monster movies
and here they repeat the news style that
was seen at the start of both godzilla
and kong skull island
and at the end of king of the monsters
these sections give cool bits of
redacted text
that break the fourth wall and fill in
things about its plot
characters and the crew behind it
director adam wingard's section reads
the history of the titan wars will be
explored in a film by adam wingard
that sheds light on previously hidden
truths you also see
one which discusses how the monster
sounds are compared to music by tom
hulkenberg
who is the film's composer there's also
a moment in which we see
decades of research into ancient stories
leads to a legendary pictures production
which it was decades it feels like
because the movie got delayed so much
now these nods extend to the plot of the
movie
as we can see one which reads alexander
scores god needs to prove the existence
of hollow earth
to salvage his tarnished reputation this
is of course the journey that the
character goes on in the film
so it's a nice bit of foreshadowing in
these moments there's another that reads
countless explorers have attempted to
prove the connection eyes are gonzales
and many have perished
which does foreshadow her death later on
we can also see in the cave paintings
and ancient art that kong holds an axe
and later when we cut to his
characteristics
we can also make out that he's able to
use tools namely an axe
this of course sets up him discovering
his ancestors old weapons one of which
was likely used in this painting
and probably also becomes the one that
kong goes on to bear
we can see that his weaknesses are
flammable attacks which is one way that
the humans were able to hold him off in
conscious island
you can make out that his enemies are
giant squids and skull crawlers
the both of which he fought in his solo
movie there's also a titan listed
and though up until this point we
haven't seen him fight one
it does tease the eventual showdown you
also catch bill randa
aka john goodman's expedition in 1973 to
skull island
and alongside him we can see a giant
skull of a kong ape
something that appears in one of its
many scenes at the apex facility we
follow bernie
and then jump to nathan lind at denham
university
this is actually a callback to call
denham the director in the 1933 film
who led the journey to skull island they
take kong across the sea
and the chains that are used to hold
them in place are extremely some of the
ones that he was forced to wear in the
original kong
we can see that he's sedated using green
juice something that was also used to
knock him out by the humans in king kong
vs godzilla
at night jia goes out to visit him and
the pair touch fingers
which is aping pun intended the creation
of man by michelangelo
this imagery is brought back up in the
hollow earth when kong leaps across the
sky
and we see a rock shaped like a finger
reaching out which he then touches
the next day godzilla swims in and when
discussing this moment
adam wingard said that he wanted to echo
the barrel scene in jaws
whereas the great white pulled down one
of those with him godzilla pulls an
entire boat
and the way his fin also cuts through
the water is very similar to his sharks
the music also echoes the skydiving
scene from godzilla
and this soundtrack is pulled from
stanley kubrick's 2001
space odyssey kong is also carried
across the sky
in a moment that's reminiscent of when
this was done in the original versus
movie
using helium balloons from here the ape
and humans travel into the hollow earth
using heaves
and these ships look extremely similar
this super x aerial vehicle
which first showed up in the return of
godzilla it's very much repeating the
designs that have come before and you
know
it's sort of like poetry they rhyme now
in the hollow earth
kong pushes open the giant doors which
is a move that's very similar to the one
that you did in the 1933 film
you also see a bloody handprint which
calls back to the one that was witnessed
in skull island
here kong gains an axe which is made
from a gajira dorsal fin
and this explains how the blade can be
powered up by his energy
when this starts up we can see the
outline of a gajira further hammering
this home
this outline also circles the throne
reminding us that godzilla may be
constantly hunting the kongs
from here we cut to the fight in hong
kong godzilla is attacking
hong kong which if you look closely
has the word kong in it so yeah say
best easter eggs around the thumbs up
buttons right there now this battle is
incredible
and in it kung stuffs the handle of his
axe down godzilla's throat
which is similar to what king kong did
with a tree in the original versus movie
during it kong also tries to break
godzilla's jaw by forcing it open
which is a move that king kong did to
the t-rex back in the original 1933 film
kong is beaten but he's revived by
electricity from the heave
and this is similar to king kong vs
godzilla in which the ape is knocked out
but then revived by a bolt of lightning
anyway you're some of a [ __ ] that's all
the cool easter eggs i could find in the
film
and i hope you enjoyed the video i
didn't point out every detail as i'd be
here forever
but you know what i'm gonna give you the
opportunity to make me look like the
idiot
and write in the comments below which
ones i missed as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize through on the 30th
of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league on 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is drop a thumbs up
make sure you subscribe the
notifications on and comment below with
anything that i missed or if you just
liked the video or if you hated it
and the winners of last month's
competition are on screen right now so
if that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the ending of the film
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire platform top
to bottom
talking about what we liked talked about
what we didn't it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video
i've been poor let's see you next time
take care peace